Sheep in press vests outside the offices of
Novaya Gazeta in Moscow.
The display might look cute, but it's no petting
zoo.
Instead, its part of the latest scare campaign
against the opposition newspaper.
Just a few days before, the journalists received
a severed sheep's head and a funeral wreath
addressed to the editor-in-chief and the journalist
Denis Korotkov.
Korotkov has worked for Novaya Gazeta from
St. Petersburg since September.
Even in this Café in the center of the city
he worries about surveillance.
On the internet he has been accused of being
a traitor.
The wave of online hate is connected to his
investigation into the dealings of Putin's
cohort Evgeny Prigozhin.
He is allegedly behind the so-called troll
factory, which pays people to promote the
Kremlin's interests online - and behind a
controversial Russian mercenary group.
"They put my addresses on the internet, information
about my relatives, about members of my family
- and they openly discuss online about what
to do to me.
Can I say that I find that pleasant and enjoyable?
Of course I don’t.
But do I feel a certain satisfaction, because
these threats mean that I wrote the right
thing?
Yes."
Korotkov's colleagues in Moscow at their daily
planning conference.
The newspaper is one of the last truly critical
media outlets in Russia.
For over 25 years Novaya Gazeta has been highly
regarded for its investigative articles into
corruption and human rights abuses.
For years now, the journalists here have felt
the restrictions on press freedom in the country
tighten.
Six of the paper's journalists have paid for
their reporting with their lives.
- Including Anna Politkovskaya.
She was murdered in 2006.
Politkovskaya was known for her critical reporting
about the conflict in Chechnya.
An element of fear has become part of everyday
life at Novaya Gazeta.
“Our newspaper has lost as many journalists
as if we were reporting during wartime – even
though Russia is not at war.
It's like working in a minefield.”
"If you had to choose whether they should
send a sheep's head or come without warning
and murder someone, then I'd rather have a
severed sheep's head every single day."
The Head of the Russian Journalists' Union
on the other hand, says the bigger picture
when it comes to press freedom in Russia is
positive.
"I think in Russia both the journalists and
the government are still learning how to communicate
with each other.
And even though there are problems, there
is overreach, there are violations that verge
on censorship, nevertheless the situation
overall is improving.
And, internationally speaking, the situation
in Russia is decent."
But to Denis Korotkov, his work certainly
feels dangerous.
He sees the risk as a given, a normal part
of his investigative reporting that he is
willing to accept.
Though it has meant that even his daughter
has been threatened.
"I am interested in uncovering stories that
you can't see with the naked eye.
Things that aren't right on the surface.
Dealings that are secret are usually criminal
dealings.
Of course, when you do this work you can take
on airs of "nothing can stop me."
But of course I have my limits.
And God forbid if my opponents ever sound
out what those limits are."